we're not necessarily involved in this
kind of judgment ourselves but we
recognize the phenomenon in our society
well enough the more someone earns the
more they're likely to be admired by
strangers and perceived as interesting
and exciting respect appears all too
often to be directly awarded according
to earnings and in a related move if you
don't have much economic endorsement it
can be hard for your character or views
to be taken seriously it's not a mystery
that this relationship got established
because there are so many conspicuous
cases where we find a genuine link
between talent effort skill contribution
and income the most impressive examples
involve brilliant surgeons the authors
of Matilda and Harry Potter or the team
behind the development of graphene all
these geniuses had a lot of talent they
made a lot of money and their
contributions are terrific they make the
connections between a high income and
virtue seem right and natural but turn
to the pages of economics textbooks and
a very different far less emotive
account of wages emerges economics
states that wages are determined not by
social contribution but by the number of
people able and willing to do a given
job that others want done if there are
lots of people able to complete the task
you won't need to offer very much money
to get their labor and if there are very
few people able to do the job you'll
have to pay a lot more but note that
there is no room to judge the worth of
the work being done the determinant of
wages is just the strength of demand in
relation to supply taken in one
direction this explains the high salary
of a hitman a person who can for the
most exacting and difficult missions
where the target possesses private
guards and is protected by triple-glazed
security glass extract an early
seven-figure sum simply because almost
no one on earth is capable of carrying
out such a complex manoeuvre taken in
the other direction the same theory of
wages explains the salary of the modern
hospice nurse charged with accompanying
people through their last days a task as
meaningful as one could imagine yet
whose yearly salary is a tiny fraction
the murderous stipend in neither case
through the wages have any connection to
the contributions being made it simply
has to do with how many people are
capable of carrying out a task and how
much demand there is for it it so
happens that in our society some really
wonderful qualities like consideration
sympathy and hard work are actually
rather widespread which has a deeply
paradoxical consequence you can employ
someone with astonishing qualities and
get away with offering them pretty much
nothing at all the whole economic system
can seem entirely lacking in justice and
our minds rebel against the gross
violation of the principles of fairness
it's normal if we should then scan the
horizon in the hope of finding some
answers that can lessen the pain in the
history of the West have been two huge
intellectual attempts to resolve the
impression of injustice around wages the
first is Christianity a doctrine which
has insisted that a person's worth is to
be determined in an entirely different
sense to the financial after death a
person's soul will be weighed by God and
his or her true merits perfectly
rewarded for eternity wages can't change
here on earth but the meaning of the
wage will in the eyes of Christianity be
altered and the humiliation of poverty
should hence lose some of its bitter
sting the other huge attempt to
introduce justice was Marxism Karl
Marx's work argued for a new world in
which workers would for the first time
be rewarded according to the worth of
their contributions to society so down
would go the wages of a hit men casino
owners and mining tycoons and up would
go the wages of the nurse and the farmer
communism would return justice to
incomes in their own day these seemed
like very impressive solutions yet for
different reasons they're not in any way
things we can now put our hopes on the
current economic order is pretty firmly
established and is not about to change
anytime soon but the hopes remain for
some way of dealing with the disjuncture
between wages and contribution
it may be an odd place to look but the
most immediately usable solution to the
situation may lie in a really unexpected
place the walls of an upper gallery in
the Wallace Collection
in London's Manchester square home to a
small painting called the lace maker by
a little-known German artist called
Casper Nature who painted it in 1664
we've caught the lace maker in what
looks like a quiet mid-afternoon she's
concentrating on a difficult task
carefully threading her needle it will
take her around five hours to make just
one square centimeter her eyes will tire
she'll make something dazzling and
moving an externalization of the best
sides of her nature
and yet her reward for the exquisite
craftsmanship will be a few pennies at
best lace making was a major industry
for women in the 17th and 18th centuries
but as it happens it was also one of the
lowest paid for a stubborn unbudgeted
now to understand lots of people could
do this work interestingly many artists
were drawn to paint lace makers at their
task the artists had no hopes of
reforming how lace makers got paid but
they had an ambition to change the lives
of lace makers nevertheless they wanted
to use art to alter the status of these
lace makers by directing viewers to the
intelligence and dignity of the craft of
lace making they hope to redeem the
social standing of this economically
slighted class what the artists were
doing with lace makers reflects a
general capacity of art to redraw what
we think of as prestigious and to return
proper appreciation for what certain
people especially those deemed marginal
by the dominant social hierarchy are and
do sadly for all the status we accorded
art is actually a pretty small thing in
the world
but the move that art has made needs to
and can be redeployed on a much larger
scale art is a mechanism for
appreciation which is particularly adept
at a close study of the ways in which an
individual might be deserving of
tenderness sympathy and admiration and
yet neglected by the wider world the
goal of art is to increase the amount of
dense and accurate information about
people's jobs so that we can stop using
mere wages as our measuring-rods once we
get to know people well in
otherwise the state of their bank
balance invariably declines a little and
what they're really bringing to their
tasks starts to emerge along with a
fairer way of distributing honor and
respect if you like our films take a
look at our shop the School of Life comm
forward slash shop you'll find lots of
thoughtful books games stationery and
more
you